he's the senior nba writer covering the
nba and the lakers for the athletic
it's good to have joe vardon back on the
program joe where are you right now
uh coronado springs in lake buena vista
florida okay now how much access
freedom do you have to come and go
inside the hotel
so what i've been doing is when i get a
knock on my door for my food
i open the door very slowly and i stand
on both sides of the uh of the door for
several seconds to milk as much
fresh air as i can out of picking up my
food um
because that's it the only time you can
open your door is to pick up your food
uh or to step outside for just a second
to get the covent test
that's the only freedom i have for the
until monday can you visit other members
of the media
no you can't walk down the hall no
and first of all uh you know with with
most of the disney hotels it's not um
they're they aren't marriotts so it's
more of a motel feel like
the the hall there is no hallway it's
just outside okay
um but yeah can't yeah you can't do
anything but
how long does this go for um as long as
i
continue to test negative uh for for the
virus
i will be allowed out of quarantine on
monday so it's a
it's a seven or eight day quarantine any
yard time this
feels like shawshank redemption can you
hit the weights
no and um i i just finished uh
my second workout in quarantine which is
i do uh 100 push-ups sit-ups squats
uh dips and burpees and then i
run from see if i could do this on my
camera here
i run from that sink
to that door and back uh for 20 minutes
it was a little over two miles
so that's uh that's my yard time my man
and then i uh i wipe the sweat up off
the floor and try to clean up and
turn this into a workspace i did shower
before coming off
how confident are you this is will start
on time and that will actually
crown a champion um a hundred percent
on the start time okay i think we're
great and i don't know i mean
um i still am in that stage where i feel
like they've done this right and they've
done this well and it will probably work
and i don't even want to say maybe i
mean i i really think that this is going
to happen
um maybe it's in part because of all the
protocols i have to go through and i
just feel like everybody here is doing
it
for the most part and um the thing that
feels the best is
i feel like if if you step out of line
and do something dangerous they're gonna
catch you
uh and you will be punished as as we
have seen already with these two guys
who have broken quarantine
and explain what they did to break
quarantine like how how does that happen
that you're ordering
food and it's being delivered and did
somebody
rat out one of these players or both of
these players yeah i think so
i mean um you know what we
with the case of of bruno um he was
i think he had a buddy uh who was trying
who was gonna drive him
up something that he wanted like
something to wear um while he was
while he was down here and just
lost his mind like you it's so
unequivocally clear
that uh that you cannot leave your room
while you're in quarantine
um and then of the case with the case of
holmes right like he went too
far and picking up the food that he had
ordered um
you know i mean i guess you can call
these mistakes but they really
they aren't i think it's more of just um
not being used to having to follow a
certain set of rules
and uh and and you know i think that
reality is going to set in here
i like the rockets as a dark horse here
we'll get into who you like and uh are
the lakers still the favorites here but
russell westbrook testing positive he's
acknowledged
that he tested positive we're still
waiting for
uh james harden uh yeah but what
is there a reason why he's not there
yeah i mean i'm i'm sure it's it's
because of of the virus
um he just has chosen not to
uh announce it and the the teams can't
do it
unless uh they have the players uh
permission so
you know as of a couple days ago you had
mike d'antoni saying well these three
players aren't here and we can't say why
uh and then russ kind of comes out
yesterday and
says that he has in fact had the virus
and then just the time frame so
westbrook is going to start on time uh
well
we don't know that i mean we we don't
know um you have d'antoni saying
first earlier in the week well yeah
they'll all probably be here by midweek
and then last night it was well
i hope that's what happens i'm not sure
i mean here's here are the rules
um once you test positive okay you have
to have you have to have these things
you have to be asymptomatic
um you have to record two net
consecutive negative tests over a period
of longer than 24 hours
you have to go through a complete
medical screening uh
and and then for if you're a player you
have to
clear a heart screening because
apparently there's some cardio
related issues here so
those are the rules um when they got
sick we don't know
or when they contracted the virus we
don't know um
typically what doing everything i just
said could take up to two weeks so
you know i don't know how long this is
going to be for those guys
i think they will be back in time to
start the season on on july 30th but
don't know we talked we're talking to
joe vardon uh senior nba writer covering
the nba and the lakers for the athletic
and speaking of
the lakers with avery bradley not there
now rajon rondo
out for at least six weeks how big a
deal is this
for the lakers the the um avery bradley
thing is huge
i really do i think it weakens them um
it certainly affects
them defensively on the perimeter and
when you look at how
deep the clippers are and how healthy
the clippers are now which they really
had never been the whole season
i think there is a lot to be concerned
about on the lakers the the rondo issue
i mean yeah
he was their backup point guard um he
was taking the ball
uh when lebron was was on the bench and
that that certainly matters
um this had not been a good season for
for rajon
um and certainly he had been discussed
as as a potentially weaker
link in this laker team uh around the
trade deadline
and ultimately they didn't make a move
there really so
um you know i don't know what the
options are
per se when with with rajan out but but
of the
the two injuries i definitely think it's
bradley who do you
uh favor coming out of the west the
clippers i think
um and you know i mean you know dan i've
spent most of my nba career covering
lebron
um i don't like to bet against him
certainly in in 2018 and cleveland was
um one of the most unsung acts of
basketball heroism that'll probably ever
go uh him getting that team that far
um but i just i am bowled over by the
clipper situation right now
healthy paul george healthy kawhi
leonard
super deep with all the uh the moves
that were made around the trade deadline
um i i i don't know i think they're the
team to be
but if but if the lakers had bradley and
rondo
would you feel different no um listen i
i
you know i i think the lakers had a
fantastic
regular season i really commend that
such an uh i mean they're an old team
with the new coach
and frank vogel um i really commend for
how they went about their business
and them catching the bucks and being in
first place at the time of the pandemic
hitting was
is awesome but you know these nba
seasons are
funny and and we actually often see that
the best regular season team
doesn't win doesn't always doesn't get
to the finals
or necessarily win it um and in the case
of the clippers they were always
kind of doing this slow build
and they probably more than any team
benefit from
you know this three and a half four
month layoff the degree of difficulty
though
is like i can't if you win the title
this year
i get there's no asterisk the whole
season has an asterisk but
it feels like this joe that
those who don't like lebron creeping up
on michael jordan
will add an asterisk to this that this
is different
than anything that michael the cop like
it's just weird and and you've been
around a lot you know lebron all
you know for most of his career it feels
like people go out of their way to
attach things to bring lebron down a
notch
your thoughts if he does win a title
with this team
well i just i would like someone uh
to explain to me uh how the
how these differing circumstances would
then suggest
that that a title doesn't count i mean
you still have to win
four four games and four playoff series
um the teams aren't any worse
you know like they everybody has their
players at the start of this and if
somebody goes out
with the virus well how is that actually
different from them going down with an
acl or a
you know an ankle um when you talk about
degrees of difficulty i mean i guess
sure there you don't have to go um into
you know milwaukee's what is it five
serve forum i think is the new
arena there you don't have to go there
in june and win
but you know you also don't get to play
at staples center and in the meantime
everybody has the same you know crappy
being away from your family
being out of your own bed for three
months without stop i mean
i i just i i don't i don't get it
from for this asterisk stuff um and if
lebron wins another one now i mean
geez that's what that's for um on what
three different teams that's
that's pretty good i also wonder about
this joe and you uh
made mention of this this is an old team
and i wonder
what will the lakers look like next year
because lebron knows that the clock is
ticking you still have anthony davis and
hopefully he stays but
uh you know kyle kuzma this is a kyle
kuzma moment to step up
and play big boy basketball as well but
what do you think this lineup this
roster looks like uh next year with the
lakers
yeah i mean i think you know i think
you're going to see turnover for sure
it's it's hard to um it's hard to know
how this pandemic affects free agency
and affects teams various cap situations
and contract situations with options and
whatnot
um i i think that that lebron and
anthony are together for at least one
more year
you know i i've been thinking about this
it's funny you know that you asked it
because i i was thinking about this this
morning
on my run from the mirror to the door um
you know
lebron was probably going to play a
couple more years
um you know he's 35 now he'll be 36 in
december
i i think he would at least play out
this contract with the lakers and i
suppose that's probably still true but
the added stress of the virus
um i just wonder if it's taking years
off of
his career i mean he's like i said he's
gonna be 36
he's been through so much and when it
gets more and more dangerous to play
this game
what else does he need to do um how much
time
does he want to spend away from those
boys uh in the middle of all this so
you know i have not spoken to him since
march i guess
um and i haven't seen him so i'm not
saying i know that that this is cutting
his
career short but i wonder i mean he's
he's got
all these businesses he's getting more
involved politically
um i you know i i could see
this being something that weighs on a
guy when you can start to consider how
much longer you want to play
what's he chasing yeah i mean
so after he won in cleveland in 2016 he
said what i'm chasing michael's ghost
which meant he's chasing six
theoretically he has time but you know
he's probably not gonna get there
and so you know his leg his legacy
was cemented when he won in cleveland i
think that's true
um i don't think he can hurt it uh
by playing with the lakers especially
because he did rebound from a bad start
um you know i mean
if if he is second best does winning
another one make him first best
uh no he i don't think so but but um
so yeah i i don't know how much i don't
know what else he is chasing it's just
more about
enjoying what you're doing in life and
you know what's gonna happen
if kawhi wins a title with the clippers
so now he's won three titles with three
different franchises
all of a sudden that will reduce what
lebron
accomplished if he doesn't win a title
with the lakers
you know i hadn't thought of it like
that dan but you're probably right
um it's just kawhi
like i don't know how many titles kawhi
has to win to get into the discussion
with lebron
um and he's probably not going to get
there because he's not a regular season
performer
oh yeah but but you know if he's winning
titles
um i don't know he's i it feels like
though lebron
we we've said oh man he's won titles
with cleveland and he won with miami now
if he wins with the lakers
but if kawhi beats him to the punch then
i
it just feels like people say yeah so
what kawhi did it before
lebron yeah no i think you're right
i think but some of this has to do with
um
your star power when just when you're
talking about when you get
into these kinds of discussions and
like kawhi just isn't lebron he's
like he's he's not um he's not the same
personality which i think matters i mean
if you look at
you know i mean michael certainly was
that and lebron certainly was that and
then behind him
you know kobe was that i mean i don't
know what your order is but i'm just
saying
that that matters and uh when you're
when you get into these barbershop
discussions and
kawhi just doesn't have that personality
he never has
but i wonder and i i brought this up
when we do those top 10 lists or
greatest players of all time
who's moving in in let's say the next
five
to seven years and who's moving out of
the top ten
list you know cause durant steph curry
kawhi greek freaks not there yet to move
into the top ten but if
if you see like steph curry is a top 10
player of all time
would you say durant top 10 player of
all time and if that's the case
is carl malone moving out is
larry bird moving out because somebody's
got to move out if these guys are moving
in
i mean does i think durant's probably
probably already there um
oh as far as top five you know i i just
i don't know i get tripped up by this
stuff dan
oh i knew two no i do too joe i don't
know i i mean like
i was thinking about this as you were
talking i was thinking about it from
the tiger woods perspective um he's on
my mind because he's coming back to play
this week in golf
in the city between our two hometowns uh
and you know we uh
like it when when rory came out came on
to tour and jordan
spieth like those two were they were
gonna be the next tiger
and neither one of them turned out to be
the next tiger
and so like we have a top five i guess
and we have like
like lebron absolutely took the mantle
from from michael he he was the heir
uh still is um who who is the next one i
mean
there's gonna be one but it we have seen
throughout history that they don't come
automatically right away like they
aren't there
immediately to take the reins and so
maybe it's giannis maybe it's zion um
you know steph and
steph and kevin durant are great but
they're older players like neither one
of them have a ton of time left and
kevin durant is coming off that injury
that
you don't know uh like it's the worst
injury you can have in the nba
so i mean how good is he gonna be i'm
not sure um
so i you know i i don't know that
there's there's much movement in the
next five to seven years yeah i feel
like if one of those guys wins
another title especially if steph steph
might already be there because he's
considered the best
shooter of all time and uh you know so
that that carries a lot of cachet
if the nba could give zion a buy
into the dude into the first round to
face the lakers would they do that
if they could do that privately that
they could manipulate it and have zion
face the lakers in the opening room
listen yeah they have already
yes yes they've already quasi done it i
mean
you know they set up the the
whole nba regular season tv schedule
last summer
for this season on zion williamson
i mean yes lebron had something to do
with it too yes the warriors had
something to do with it too but
the whole thing was set up for him and
a week before the season starts he has
surgery on his knee or he announced that
that's what's going to happen i mean
that wrecked their whole thing cost them
millions of dollars
in tv ratings it did yeah and so now
they've set up this uh
this postsea like this restart basically
with this totally unique set of rules so
zion has a chance um to get back into
the playoffs i mean
yes they would do that yeah uh it's
great to talk to you
be safe i'm gonna go outside and get
some fresh air though joe
is that's fine that's okay and probably
get a bite to eat or something like that
yeah go hang out with someone think of
me no i will thank you joe we appreciate
your time
thanks for having me that's uh joe
vardon he covers the nba for the
athletic